you know our meeting was
[ __ ] i want to get to it right it
was [ __ ] it was hollywood i didn't
like it
but um he's a really funny stand-up
um he's from new york and i just been a
fan of a stand-up he's so quick on his
feet
and he you know he it's that crop of
kids
from new york you know normand
mark normand is that his name yeah he's
done our podcast love him
schultz right these white dudes
this new breed of white dude i'm telling
you right now
this new breed of white dudes coming up
is so impressive they put chills down my
[ __ ] spine
yeah okay and this dude is in that class
of white dudes are gonna run [ __ ]
right i'm being pretty real that's real
dude that's real honest
my opinion yeah yeah samurail give him
an applause
thank you why was there me what was it
i'm gonna tell you i mean tell me
you and i did something [ __ ] bro
what do we do i'm gonna tell you
so i'll be honest with you yeah i have
never met you before in my life
okay but when we're at the comedy store
once you were in the hallway
right and i knew who you were and i
think you knew who i was
yeah so i walked up to you and we acted
as if
we had already met before i'm like so
you're gonna do my podcast oh yeah yeah
i'd love
to do it man i'm in town this and that
and we just talked we had this like
we no dude we had this rhythm as if
we did the like i'm sam i'm bob nice to
meet you this is that we didn't do that
yeah
right it was as if we just hollyweeded
it like
very hollywood i thought you were just i
thought you knew that i was visiting and
looked uncomfortable and were just being
friendly i didn't think it was hollywood
i thought you were just being nice
yeah but when you meet a human being for
the first time
don't you go my name is sam i think
i think for some reason in la i'm never
here so i think
some people have just like messaged with
here and there and then they're just
they just do that
yeah maybe it's hollywood i don't know
yeah i don't you know
because you know like andrew schultz
when i first met him
he goes my name is andrew you know
because
because it's just like what human beings
do right yeah and i was also a
kindergartner
right but here's another thing that i
knew and maybe
this is gonna be hard to say i'm gonna
say it
you're great and like i said before
you're one of the new
you know but you're also a power couple
with taylor okay sure okay no honestly
because
in terms of female comics
it's just comics i shouldn't even say
that because you know i'm woke
i'm slept but woke at the same time
sometimes i'm sleeping but then i wake
up
oh there it is yeah yeah yeah and and
and i gouge my eyes out and i go
she is not just you know she's one of
the best
up and coming from this side of the the
country
absolutely right and then you're new
york coming up there
and then you guys are together yeah
right now dating
is that out there people know that i
mean you don't like it yeah i don't
i mean i don't know it's fine yeah yeah
but here's some that's what also i know
which gives it an added like power